it's the muslim holiday of eden srinagar
the largest city in indian administered
kashmir
under the tightest security in a week
[Music]
worshipers attend prayers but only in
neighborhood mosques
a peaceful protest followed
these kashmiris are angry at the indian
government's decision
to revoke their autonomy
for muslims there are two days which are
festive and sacred
and that's eid but this is not our eid
we are just mourning in kashmir the
government says
security restrictions are being eased in
most areas in jammu
and parts of kashmir valley
our policy is greater relaxation and
greater easing out so that people can
come out
and greet each other but at the same
time we are keeping a watch on the
situation
if there are any mischievous elements
who want to disturb peace
we'll be tough with them
in new delhi these kashmiri students
made the best of the holiday
far away from home they say they haven't
been able to speak to their families
for over a week they gather for a feast
but their minds are on the events
unfolding back home
this is for the first time that you know
we have not been able to go home or talk
to our parents on an
important day which is not only
personally speaking not only religiously
important but culturally important as
well because we have not been able to
speak home i have not spoken to my
family for 70 years
some kashmiris and activists gathered in
the heart of the capital
determined to get their voices heard
there is anger and frustration among
these kashmiris in new delhi
stunned by the extent of the
communication blackout that's stopping
them from reaching their families
especially during the muslim holiday of
eid the government says
these restrictions are temporary but its
impact can be felt
on the daily lives of those cut off from
the outside world
priyanka gupta al jazeera new delhi